well indeed but having said that we have
thought this in our a few months just
after the Scottish referendum the SNP
but shot all the seats surely not all is
it sure but we for quite a while now
thought the SP might win over fifty
there are 59 seats in Scotland we never
thought they would win 59 and frankly we
still don't quite think they'll do that
well but it's quite likely they'll win
around 55 or so at the moment you talk
rubbish man is what labour would say
well they might but I think if you get
to the more honest labor strategist
they'll admit that at best there are
very good swimmers swimming against a
tsunami there's not very much they can
do to overcome what seems to be a big
structural shift in Scotland paint the
political landscape landscape for me
from the 8th of May in Scotland robust
detail well both but let's start with
Scotland well I think what you'll see in
Scotland is the Lib Dems holding on to
one of their 11 seats organ Shetland so
they'll be right at the top of the
country but otherwise wiped out you'll
see labour lose almost all of their 41
seats they won in 2010 in FEC Jim Murphy
seat looks like it may be gone Gordon
Brown seco caddy is going to be gone
he's stepping down but whoever's
replaced sure by hoping to replace so
labour mining it was one or two and
they'll probably be tucked around
Glasgow but the rest of Scotland will be
yellow and then finally the bottom of
the country there's three big when you
say yellow it's not for the Lib Dems I
don't I think I think wasn't as orange
okay I don't think they know what their
color is either if you think about the
the final party the Tories who are
actually doing rather better and they
were last month in Scottish part
surprisingly they may actually win all
three of the big border seats in the
south of Scotland they hold one of them
and they might win another two and if
that was the case then remarkably the
Tories would have more seats and
Scotland labour in Scotland I
interviewed Nicola Sturgeon quite
recently she said the only neutral color
and Scot of this pink okay which is an
interesting point for you keep that in
your back pocket not having parties no
pink party is apparently not so what
does that mean then the fact that the
SNP will have 50 odd votes what does
that mean as far as the makeup of
Westminster is concerned because that
means the Lib Dems presumably at the
water well they will be in Scotland but
actually the Lib Dems are
- hold on surround half of their seats
but the picture links how many were
around 27 28
the Big Bear anus is the third biggest
party anymore they won't the SNP will
their aim is to get 30 the big picture
here though is that while labour are
being wiped out in Scotland that doesn't
necessarily harm ad Miliband chances of
being a number 10 because those SNP MPs
are almost certain they've committed to
voting Cameron out of Downing Street so
when we think about which party or which
Prime Minister's is going to be there on
May 8th or a few weeks after May Ed
Miliband can count on the support of
Alex he's not doing a deal with them he
said no way no have you don't have to do
a deal with them that they can choose
who to vote for all that Miliband is
saying is he's not going to do a
coalition with them no he didn't what if
even you may link further but even a
confidence supply deal doesn't preclude
the fact that the SNP can vote with him
ed Miliband can't tell the SNP how to
vote and the point is that we're
assuming the SNP will vote whether they
stop following me in their mind anyway
sure but I think the point is Ed
Miliband can't tell the SNP what to do
and the SNP have committed to voting
David Cameron down and so when we think
about who's going to be Prime Minister
after this election we can add labour
and SP seats together and assume they'll
vote as one block at least initially but
a national government
well it seems unlikely we haven't had
one since the war so national government
is when the two main parties would vote
together or form a government together
they go to the Queen and say yeah we
feel that we can we can run the country
like this for a while you don't think
that's going to happen well they're very
divided on many policies is hard to see
how they could reconcile themselves okay
so how do you see the political
landscape at Westminster then come the
8th of May well I think that the
important point is even though the
Tories seem to be doing better in a
tional polls now than they were a few
weeks ago they really need to be leading
by about 3 points maybe even four points
for David Cameron to be sure staying in
number 10 because if the parties are
tied in the polls then they probably can
be approximately tied in on seats and so
even if David Cameron wins a few more
seats the maths just means that Ed
Miliband is far more likely to get to
three hundred and twenty three seats
which is what he needs
vote Cameron down and take power and
that's going to be because of the SNP
you say three to three because of shin
fan who don't take up their cell phone
to take the seats and the speaker
doesn't count okay so um how do you very
much jiggery-pokery do you think will be
chess games will be going on in the
weekend after the election I think we
will see endless whatever you like to
call yeah you're not going to use that
word okay that's right
unless negotiations I mean there's going
to be this amazing spectacle there after
the election where all the party leaders
need for VE Day at the Cenotaph at
around lunch coding Nicola Sturgeon
really I didn't know that well so we're
going to be able to watch that and then
there's going to be all sorts of things
going on behind closed doors
um the Prime Minister though can remain
no resigning straight and unless to try
to form a government
absolutely the Prime Minister remains
the prime minister until labour can
prove that they will be able to command
the confidence of the house how exactly
that's done it's quite complicated but
David Cameron is is very likely to
remain Prime Minister least in the
immediate aftermath next week which is
what we saw with Gordon Brown didn't
play we did but in 2010 Gordon Brown
came so far behind you of a Cameron he
lost by around 50 seats that it was very
hard to deal no didn't mean he did but I
think it's far more likely you'll see
labour going and trying to deal with
more Hope than Gordon Brown did in 2010
I think it's fascinating so do i great
well chat you again for now thank you
very much you do thanks a lot